let's say that you wanted to build a
good habit and breaking a bad one one of
the laws is to make it obvious and this
largely comes down to like what we're
exposed to each day and minimalism and
simplicity plays a big role in this and
the book I call it environment design
that's basically the strategy for a long
time I realized that I brushed my teeth
twice a day but I didn't floss
consistently and when I looked at that
habit one of the reasons that I wasn't
flossing consistently is because the
floss was hidden in the drawer in the
bathroom so I just wouldn't see it I
bought a little bowl and got some of the
pre-made flossers and put them in the
bowl and place it right next to my
toothbrush so now I brush my teeth put
the toothbrush down pick the flosser up
it's right there just that one little
environment design change is pretty much
all I needed to do to build the habit of
flossing every day you know a lot of
people feel like they spend too much
time watching TV or playing video games
or just looking at a screen but if you
walk into pretty much any living room
where do all the couches and chairs face
they all face the television so it's
like what is that room designed to get
you to do it's designed to get you to
watch TV there are a variety of levels
to this you could for example take the
remote and take it off of the coffee
table and put it inside a drawer but the
point here and this is kind of the the
principle of environment design in
general which is you want to put fewer
steps between you and the good behaviors
and more steps between you and the bad
ones and imagine the cumulative impact
of living an environment that exposes
you to the cues of your positive habits
and reduces the cues of your negative
habits it's kind of like you're just
gently being nudged in the right
direction each day and that's just one
of the ways that you can sort of design
a system that leads you into better
habits need motivation what's the top 10
We Believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best James clear and my take on
his top 10 rules of success enjoy
rule number two don't get trapped in
motion just take someone who's trying to
get in shape I mean people will
what kind of protein powder should I get
what knee sleeves do I need what are the
best uh weightlifting shoes and all that
stuff is like the last two percent of
difference that it's mostly like don't
miss workouts and get your reps in this
is what in the book I call the
difference between motion and action uh
action can actually deliver a result uh
but motion is related to that but never
will
um you know like going to the gym and uh
talking to a personal trainer about
signing up that's fine that's related to
getting in shape but it doesn't matter
how many times you talk to a personal
trainer you're never going to get in
shape uh whereas like doing 10 squats
that actually can do something it's like
talking to the trainer's motion doing
squats is action yeah um and yeah I
think a lot of times people get trapped
in motion they get trapped in analysis
paralysis because it is a way to feel
like you're making progress without
running the risk of failure rule number
three avoid distraction every day I try
to leave my phone in another room
outside of my office at least until
lunch because then I get like a four
hour block of time in the morning where
I can just work without any distraction
yeah and
um it's funny how quickly you don't like
if my phone was on me in the morning I
would check it like you know every five
minutes or whatever but when it's out of
the room I don't even find myself
wanting to I never walk up the stairs to
go check it even though it's only 30
seconds away wow so it's it's
interesting how
um little we actually want to do these
things but we just do them all the time
because they're obvious and easy and I
think the key is to invert that take the
things that are the bad habits the
distractions the procrastinations the
unproductive uses of time and make them
more invisible reduce exposure and less
less easy to do and take the things that
are good habits and make it the
equivalent of having your phone on you
all the time right and make it right in
front of you make it obvious make it
easy make it
um you know frictionless rule number
four build one habit at a time what
really changes your your outcomes or
what really moves your life in a
positive direction is not a single like
1 percent change or a single a little
habit it's a collection of them all
organized towards the same like overall
goal or overall outcome so you know
sometimes people will
they get like a you know Fitbit and they
start
they get a Fitbit and they start walking
10 000 steps a day or something like
that and then they get frustrated after
three months because they haven't seen
this change in the mirror this change on
the scale or whatever but it's like well
that's good but that's just one habit
related to your health you don't need
um you don't need a single little habit
you need like a thousand of them and
once you kind of build this collection
of them all moving you in the same
direction it's kind of like each one
adds a little grain of sand to the side
of the scale and eventually you tip the
scales in your favor and I think that's
another reason to start with one habit
at a time is that you naturally sort of
pick up other behaviors that are related
to the overall thing that you're working
on in the moment and um and that helps
to keep you focused rather than trying
to do two or three things then you get
scattered also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all of the
Lessons Learned in this video as well as
pull out our three favorite learnings
and quotes that will inspire you to
actually do something the worksheet will
also give you space to write down what
your key takeaways are and your specific
plan of action to make sure you're
getting results if you want the
worksheet design specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five create
satisfaction we interpret the stimuli
and the data the cues in our life
differently based on what our Viewpoint
is at that time based on what our
personality or our sorry not our
personality our personal Viewpoint is
based on what you believe your
self-image so you know I mean you see
this all the time with politics you have
the same news story that runs on the TV
but then a liberal and a conservative
interpret that data in completely
different ways and it's because of uh
what's getting echoed back to them
because of how they see themselves
because of what filter they're running
that data through and the same thing is
true if we're talking about weight loss
or or whatever else you know if like you
see a particular number on the scale and
the thing that's being echoed back to
you is I want to lose 20 pounds and feel
great then suddenly you don't feel good
about that number if the same thing if
the thing that's getting echoed back to
you is I've stuck to workouts for seven
days in a row and I feel more energetic
and healthy then you see the number in a
totally different way same number uh
just different interpretation so I think
it it's important but it's not the whole
story
and some of the the things that also
influence things are you know like what
we talked about making things obvious
making them easy but making it
satisfying the which is The Fourth Kind
of major lever that I talk about in the
book that's crucial for getting people
to come back and that can come in many
different forms
um
there's a so I guess I'll just lay the
context for this real quick there this
is really interesting to look at with a
lot of products
um so
chewing gum is a good example for many
years for hundreds of years chewing gum
was around but it was like kind of this
Bland resin it was just chewy but it
wasn't tasty and Wrigley launched in
like 1880 1890 and they came out with
Juicy Fruit and spearmint and Doublemint
and suddenly gum was chewy and it had
this immediate flavor there was like
this immediate reward to chewing it and
it took off they became the biggest
chewing gum chewing gum company in the
world
um and today many companies are doing
the same kind of thing where they're
trying to layer in a little bit of extra
satisfaction with the product so a
couple years ago BMW came out with a car
that when you press on the accelerator
it'll pipe extra engine growl through
the stereo in the in the car so it's
like more satisfying to step on the gas
um Ford just came up with another one
where they uh they the engine noise is
still there but they have this valve
that it'll only open and let the engine
noise into the car interior
um and past all the sound proofing if
you really slam on the gas and like you
know read the RPMs up but if you just
drive like normal it'll keep it soft
quiet
and so the the point there is that all
of those products cars are chewing gum
and many others they find ways to layer
immediate satisfaction into the
experience and when you do that people
want to repeat it more
anytime you have some kind of enjoyment
or a satisfying ending to a behavior
it's like this positive signal in your
brain that says hey that felt good you
should do this again next time and
that's what really gets a habit to stick
all the other stuff that we talked about
um making habits attractive making them
more obvious making more convenient to
do that gets a habit to start the first
time or makes it easier for you to do it
right then but the only reason you come
back to it is because it's satisfying
and it's really about the speed of the
satisfaction this is something that I
call the cardinal rule of behavior
change which is behaviors that are
immediately rewarded get repeated and
behaviors that are immediately punished
get avoided and the more that you can
have that positive emotional feeling
right away the more reason you have to
come back to a habit in the future rule
number six embody progress if you're
coaching someone who said I have no clue
what I'm supposed to do with my life I'm
I'm lost I have all these bad habits
smoke I drink I eat donuts every day
I have no job
my room is sloppy
and I'm just depressed
what would you say to them to get
started with changing their life around
in the form of better habits well you
just need to pick one thing first of all
I think that I just mentioned a few
minutes ago one of the most powerful
forms of motivation is progress so
seeing some progress I mean it can be as
simple as make your bed each day right
like but just doing that embodying the
identity of someone who's getting better
who's making progress just pick one
thing and use that as
this is true I mean Lewis this is
something you've probably seen with a
lot of people that you've talked to but
yeah habits are the foundation for
Mastery so if you you know say take a
take a sport like basketball
um you need to be able to dribble with
both hands without thinking before you
can worry about
what strategy you're running on offense
or what kind of you know strategic play
You're Gonna Run or what your defensive
scheme is or all this other stuff right
like you need to automate the
fundamentals of The Craft before you can
worry about the next level of
performance same thing is true for chess
you know like you need to know how the
chess pieces move automatically without
thinking about it before you can get
into all right what is my strategy going
to do and I'm going to do this and
they're gonna do that and so I think
this is true not just at the peak levels
of performance that you integrate these
habits and use habits as the foundation
for the next level of performance but
also true when you're getting started
just build one small thing carve out a
one percent change a one percent
Improvement and use that as a stepping
stone to the next uh level rule number
seven align goals with identity true
Behavior change is really identity
change
um because you're you're not really
looking to go from the type of person
who doesn't run to the type of person
who can run a 5k that's fine that's good
it's the outcome but the goal is not to
run a marathon the goal is to become a
runner the goal is not to write a book
the goal is to become a writer and once
you identify as that type of person in a
sense you're not even really pursuing
Behavior change anymore you're just
acting in alignment with the type of
person that you already believe that you
are right it's like one thing to say I
want this it's something different to
say I am this rule number eight make
decisive moments in my personal life you
know like there's a moment around 5 15
each night my wife gets home from work
and either we change into our workout
clothes and we go to the gym or we don't
change into our workout clothes and we
watch you know reruns the office in
order to take out or whatever and really
the next two hours are kind of
determined by that decisive moment of
whether we change into our workout
clothing if we change it closed then
like everything else is going to happen
automatically we're going to drive to
the gym I'll get it under the bar I'll
do it's already pre-decided basically so
one of the realizations of this and it
comes back to your kind of central
question of what you know what are the
most important habits to build or are
there ones that Ripple in other areas of
life
if you can just Master Maybe
five or ten decisive moments throughout
the day these little kind of two minute
chunks that determine the next block of
time you really only have to focus your
attention and energy on that and the the
rest of it kind of comes easily you
don't have to do that much if you can
Master the right moments it's kind of
like Judo for your personal habits you
know you apply the pressure in the right
place and everything else kind of Falls
in in line rule number nine establish a
habit if your expectations are Sky High
um you know like if you set I have a
friend who's a writer and he his goal is
to write one sentence every day and it
sounds absurd but if you set the
expectation that low then he can feel
successful pretty much every day he
always can feel satisfied by sticking to
the Habit which gives them a reason to
come back again the next day and
sometimes he writes a full page and
sometimes it's just a sentence but um if
he had set a goal of writing a thousand
words a day there would be some days
where he couldn't do that and then
suddenly he's feeling bad about that
like what if you wrote one sentence that
day he would feel bad about it even
though he still wrote that day but it's
just because of his expectation so
there's a little bit of like mental play
that's going on there in how we kind of
we sabotage ourselves by setting the bar
so high that's especially true in the
beginning I think that it becomes less
true for maybe the one or two areas
where you really want to be a master in
life like if something's really
important to you and you want Peak
Performance you want to be a
professional athlete you want to be uh
you know among the Best Authors or
something like that then maybe uh your
strategy needs to change but for most
people most of the time the strategy is
probably better to set the bar low find
a way to be satisfied and show up each
day and then once you've built the Habit
then you optimize from there this is um
I had a reader who end up losing over
100 pounds and one of the things that he
did was he went to the gym
um but he wasn't allowed to stay for
longer than five minutes and so it
sounds so weird because it's a complete
opposite of what most people do to build
a habit but he what he was doing was he
was mastering the art of showing up
um and so for six weeks he went to the
gym he'd go in do like half an exercise
and then five minutes would be up and he
go home and eventually he got to the
point where he was like you know I'm
coming here all the time I kind of feel
like staying longer right but that's
that's the opposite of the person who
takes the intermediate CrossFit class
and like kills themselves for three
weeks and then it feels totally fried
and you know gives up and then three
months later they're like oh I gotta get
back in shape
um
and so
a habit must be established before it
can be improved right often we optimize
for the Finish Line we think about the
outcome that we want we think about like
oh I want to lose 20 pounds or want to
earn six figures this year or whatever
the the thing is
um but instead if you just focus on the
first two minutes of a behavior or in
this guy's case the first five minutes
of the behavior and you optimize for the
starting line you master the art of
showing up but then you have options
then you can you actually have something
that you can improve if you're not the
type of person who shows up at the gym
even if it's just for five minutes it
doesn't even matter what your ideal
workout plan is or whatever like you
can't do anything because you're not
there and so
um in that sense I think that it's often
helpful for people especially in the
beginning to scale a habit down to the
first two minutes Master the art of
showing up and then once you're the type
of person who does it every day figure
out a way to improve angle number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is resist temptation how much
willpower do we have
so
you hear this a lot I mean it's very
common especially in self-help
motivation self-government you need to
be motivated you have to have willpower
grit and perseverance are huge and
important and it's not that those
qualities are not important it's just
that the way to develop them is
different than what most people think so
most people think I need willpower so I
should just try harder
there's an interesting body of research
I mentioned it in the book I think it's
in chapter seven on self-control and
willpower which is that the people who
appear to have the greatest self-control
actually are just tempted the least so
they face Temptations less frequently
and therefore have the Reserves and the
resources to resist it when it
occasionally comes up
and I think that this is actually like
the lever to pull or the pressure point
to push on is that the way to get better
willpower is to design an environment
that tempts you less not to say let me
just try harder
how do I become the type of person who
doesn't miss workouts and that's another
reason I like small habits because if
you have a really busy day and things
are crazy and all you can do is five
push-ups if you're oriented around the
result around the outcome it's easy to
dismiss that it's like why would I even
bother doing five push-ups it's not
going to get me in shape but some days
it's not about the result of the
training some days it's about
reinforcing being that type of person
you know like yes life was crazy and
things were really busy today and the
best I could do was getting five
push-ups in but I'm still the type of
person who doesn't miss workouts even
when it's not ideal right and in the
long run that can count for a lot which
is the kind of Twisted thing about small
habits which is that even though they're
small they can still be meaningful and
if they're meaningful they actually are
big one of the phrases I use I have us
in the book is that habits of the
compound interests of self-improvement
so it's like the same way that it's for
even compound interest you know a cruise
through Finance your the effects of your
habits multiply over time and so often
these choices that you make there's
little one percent improvements for you
or against you each day and they're very
easy to overlook on a daily basis right
like what what really is the difference
between eating a burger and fries or a
salad and chicken for lunch you don't
really taste a lot better yeah right
yeah
that's actually a crucial point that I
cover in the book which is that habits
that are immediately satisfying are more
likely to be repeated and so pretty much
any Behavior produces multiple outcomes
across time right like if you eat a
donut right now it's tasty it's so good
but in the long run you gain weight and
so the the immediate outcome is
favorable the long-term outcome is
unfavorable with good habits to soften
the reverse right like you go to the gym
right now and it takes effort you sweat
you have to work hard time for Netflix
and chill to go train the immediate
outcome is unfavorable but the ultimate
outcome you're in shape and in you know
a year or month or whatever right is
favorable and so the challenge for
building good habits and Breaking Bad
Ones is often finding a way to pull the
long-term consequences of your bad
habits into the immediate moment so you
feel a little bit of pain right now and
want to avoid it and the long-term
rewards of your good habits into the
immediate moment so you have a reason to
repeat it again in the future each
Behavior casts a vote for the type of
person that you want to become and if
you cast enough votes for that type of
identity you start to believe that about
yourself right like if you you go to
church for 20 years you believe that
you're religious you study Spanish every
Tuesday for 30 minutes you believe that
you are studious so in that way your
habits provide evidence of your desired
identity and I think that that is
probably the ultimate reason that habits
are so important it's true like habits
can help you earn more money or be more
productive or lose weight and all that
stuff is great but in addition to the
external results that habits provide
they also shape your sense of self they
like are the at the engine or the Avenue
through which you learn to believe
things about yourself like sometimes
people say stuff like
fake it till you make it but fake it
till you make it is asking yourself to
believe something without evidence for
it and you can do that for a little
while you can do it for day or week but
eventually I mean there's a word for
beliefs that don't have evidence behind
the delusion right and if you're
deluding yourself then eventually you
give up on that but the power of doing a
better habit each day or casting a
little vote for that type of person is
that now you have evidence to root your
belief in yeah six months yeah right
like I mean now you have a lot of
evidence that you're a podcaster or a
good interviewer you know like you do
this over and over again each time you
cast a vote for believing that about
yourself and you don't just you aren't
delusionally believing that you're a
good interviewer it's because you've
shown up and done it hundreds of times
right
um and so I think that that's true for
any habit large or small that they
provide evidence of the desired Identity
or the the type of person that you are
there's this professor at the University
of Florida he's retired now he was a
photography Professor his name is Jerry
ulisman and uh at the beginning of the
semester he would have this film
photography class and you bring the
class in and he would split them into
two groups he said everybody on this
side of the room you're going to be
graded on the quantity of work that you
do this semester and everybody on this
side of the room you're going to be
grading on the quality of work that you
do this semester and he's further
explained it by saying that
for your film photography you're going
to be responsible for having 100
pictures if you do 100 photos over the
course of the semester that'll be an a
if you do 90 it'll be a b if you do 80
it'll be C and so on so it's quantity
for this group you only have to produce
one photo but it has to be the most
perfect photo that you can make the best
photo that you can make
an interesting and interesting thing
happened at the end of the term all the
best grades came from the quantity group
not from the Quality Group
and what ended up happening was that
while people were busy experimenting
making mistakes learning how to you know
play with composition and so on they
would come across a really great photo
and while the quality group was busy
theorizing about what Perfection would
look like and how to take the perfect
photo and not actually honing their
skills they ended up only making
something mediocre or average
and the important Insight here
especially for habits is that in the
beginning the most important thing is
just to shut up and put your reps in
just make sure that you hone the skill
right and you can start to think of it
the way that I like to think of it is
that any outcome that you wish to
achieve is just a point along the
spectrum of repetitions so if you have
few reps to more reps and you can
imagine easy goal moderate goal a hard
goal
the more reps that you put in the more
that you more like you you are to
achieve that goal so maybe point a is
you know let's take Fitness squatting
100 pounds point B is squatting 200
Point C is squatting 300. maybe you need
to put in 100 reps or a thousand reps to
get to point a maybe it's five thousand
to get to point B maybe it was ten
thousand to get the point to c
occasionally and this is true for
everybody if you live long enough life
will come for you at some point right
like something's going to happen
um so occasionally life will stress you
but when life doesn't challenge you I
think it's important to challenge
yourself because otherwise you're just
living in this optimal environment air
conditioning and you know everything
else is super easy you can get all the
information in the world at your
fingertips you never have to like if you
think about how crazy just eating is in
the modern world so previously when we
lived in tribes you you had to expend
energy to get calories
um at a minimum you were foraging for
berries but otherwise you probably had
to like run something down and kill it
or part of a Groupon or all kinds of
other things now you can get calories
without expending any all you have to do
is just tap like uber it's on your phone
or something it'll show up at your door
and you can just sit on the couch which
is of course like a recipe for poor
health but also just it's the game has
completely changed now we've transcended
a lot of our evolutionary programming
and natural
um situations and so you need to be
careful about designing that to serve
you rather than to work against you
because it can very easily nudge you in
the other direction I think there are a
few core habits that are going to serve
everybody and certainly serve me well so
exercise is a huge one I don't do it
daily but I exercise train four times a
week yeah and I feel like if I didn't
exercise I don't know that I would be an
entrepreneur like I don't know if I
could handle the psychological roller
coaster without the physical Outlet yeah
the release the you probably feel that
as like an athlete too you know like for
being an athlete for so many years I
feel like I need to push myself
physically in addition to mentally it is
just mental it doesn't do it for me I
need to have a physical Outlet so
exercise exercise is one the other the
ultimate meta habit is reading because
if you build a habit of reading you can
solve pretty much any other problem you
know you won't learn how to be a better
podcaster you can read about that you
want to learn how to meditate you can
read about that you want to learn how to
make more money you can read about that
and so what you need is to develop a
habit of reading and then whatever
problem you're facing at the time you
can you have a method for solving that
one of my favorite studies about
exercise and they had three cohorts in
this study so they have first cohort
they said I just want you to track how
often you work out over the next few
weeks right so that's the the standard
cohort the control group second group is
that we want you to track off new
exercise we're also going to give you a
motivation motivational speech
presentation talk about the benefits of
heart health why habits are good for you
and so on so this is the motivated group
all right the third group they got the
same presentation so they're equally
motivated and then they did one thing
differently and that one thing was they
filled out this sentence is that during
the next week I will partake in at least
20 minutes of vigorous exercise on this
day in this at this time in this place
right they specifically stated their
intention to implement the behavior so
implementation and tension here's what
happened
first group one out of three of them
worked out second group motivation did
nothing as soon as they left the
researchers facility the next day they
weren't motivated it's like reading a
book or watching a YouTube or listening
to a motivational speaker and then you
forget all about it 20 minutes later
um
but the third group the group that has
specific plan for how they were going to
implement the behavior nine out of ten
of them worked out so you can increase
your odds of success two to three x just
by having a specific plan and this is
the Insight many people think that they
lack motivation when what they really
lack is clarity they think that they
need to get more motivated that they
need willpower in order to execute on a
habit if I just felt like writing if I
just felt like meditating I felt like
working out then I would do it but in
fact they don't have a plan for it and
so they wake up each day thinking I
wonder if I'll feel motivated to write
today I wonder if I'll feel motivated to
work out today but instead you can take
the decision making out of it by
explicitly stating when where and how
you will implement the Habit it sounds
easy to say let's just start a plan
let's you know write down exactly what
you should do and then maybe you'll
follow through on it but of course we
all know that there are challenges that
arise it's not quite that easy so here's
a little strategy that I like to use to
make sure you can come up with a better
plan of action and it's called a failure
pre-mortem so the way that it works is
you think about the Habit the project
the goal whatever the most important
thing is that you want to work on and I
want you to imagine fast forward six
months from now and you failed and then
tell the story of why you failed what
happened what challenges did you
encounter what was it that took you off
course
um when I do this with businesses
sometimes we call it the kill the
company exercise because everybody just
sits around thinks about ways to kill
the company in the next six months and
uh once you have all that stuff laid out
on the table in front of you you can
start to make better choices about how
to develop a plan you can start to have
if then plans so not only do I want to
exercise for 20 minutes on Monday at 5
PM but also if I do not exercise because
I have to take my kid to practice or
whatever then it's Tuesday morning at 7
A.M I will go in right you can have ways
to adjust for these challenges I think
we actually have like three options for
Breaking Bad Habits so the first option
is to reduce exposure
um so something like you know if you
want to stop spending so much money on
electronics then don't follow all the
latest tech review blogs you know like
or if you want to lose weight don't
follow a bunch of food bloggers on
Instagram
um you're constantly being triggered by
that and having to like overcome the
prompts now that doesn't always work but
if you can cut a habit off at the source
then a lot of the time like the craving
won't arise naturally so in atomic
habits in the book I talk a little bit
about this woman who she smoked while
she was in college and she would always
smoke while riding horses with a friend
and So eventually at some point she quit
smoking and she's also stopped you know
like seeing that friend and graduated
from college and so on wasn't riding
horses and then like 10 years later she
got back on a horse for the first time
and suddenly craved a cigarette and um
she was like what is going on here and
it's your habits are often tied to a
context they're tied to a situation or
some kind of cue and so if you can
reduce exposure to that cue then in many
cases the craving won't arise so that's
the first option for breaking a bad
habit the second option which kind of
sucks but is like to sit with the
craving long enough to like let this
wave of Desire ride itself out and so
you basically just resist temptation
um it's possible it's easier if
um if your hand is forced if you use
what I call a commitment device so
a brief story real quick Victor Hugo um
famous author who wrote like Hunchback
of Notre Dame and a bunch of other
things well
when he got the book deal for Hunchback
of Notre Dame he just procrastinated for
like a year he hosts a bunch of House
Parties has friends over he went
traveling for a little while yeah he
like he got the book deal he did nothing
no work
um and eventually his publisher got
pissed off they were like you know can
you please like actually work on this
and so they set this ultimatum for him
and they said uh we're gonna we're gonna
cancel the book in six months if you
don't have it done by then and so he um
he got his assistant to come in put all
his clothes into a chest and they locked
him up and took him out of the house and
the only thing he was left with was like
this the shawl this like large robe so
basically he had no clothes that were
suitable for hosting guests or for
leaving the house or like going on trips
or anything else so he more or less put
himself on house arrest
um and what ended up happening was each
time procrastination arose he was able
to kind of sit with that feeling and let
it ride because he didn't really have
many other options and then get back to
work on the book and it ended up working
he got the book done like two weeks
early but things like that where you can
lock in your future action and it
becomes really hard hard to go to your
friend's party or go out to you know
travel to a different place or whatever
um just because you don't have the
option if you can increase the friction
then sometimes you can sit with the
craving of a bad habit and let it ride
out so that's your second choice and
then the third choice is the one that
you just mentioned which is you take the
solution that the bad habit is providing
the way that it's serving you and you
find a new behavior that delivers that
same outcome what makes you an expert on
habits oh man based on lots of other
people that are talking about habits I
think that and I've said this many times
before I'm just going through this with
everybody else I consider my readers my
peers in the sense that we're all just
trying things out the only difference is
I write about what I learn and share it
each week and but we're all just
learning along the way
um early on I had a feeling like that I
was like who am I to you know I'm just a
guy who am I right about this and I had
a friend tell me the way you develop
expertise is by writing about it every
week so I wrote a new article about
habits every Monday and Thursday for
three years and that was how I developed
the expertise on the topic by writing
about it and did research right you said
here's what I found here's what I tried
here's what worked what didn't work it's
a combination of me reading the
scientific literature and reading the
research and then trying to distill the
Practical insights from that and testing
things out in my own life as a
weightlifter a Travel Photographer a
writer an entrepreneur and seeing what
that looks like and then the two
together and I think you need both like
I don't want to be some new age version
of an academic who's in an ivory Tower
just like theorizing about ideas is
different what it looks like to put
ideas into practice right like imagine
you're a Peak Performance coach and you
show up to a coach like an NBA team
these guys are like dude you need to
step on the court if you know what
you're right to see what it's actually
like you don't have to be the victim of
your environment you can also be the
architect of it you can decide to design
something to make your good behaviors
easier and your bad behaviors harder so
when it comes to habits if you want to
practice your guitar more frequently put
it right in the middle of your living
room so you run across all the time if
you want to read more when you make your
bed in the morning take the book you
want to read put it on top of the pillow
when you come back that night pick it up
read a few pages go to sleep
for me I I used to buy apples all the
time and then I would put them in the
crisper at the bottom of the fridge and
they would sit there for three weeks and
go bad and I'd finally open it up and
see them again and get mad and then
eventually I bought a bowl and put it
right in the middle of the counter and
so then when I buy apples I put them
there I see them every day and now I eat
them all the time
many of our desires are simply shaped
because we have an environment that
shapes Us in that way so the moral of
the story is I've never seen someone
stick to positive habits in a consistent
fashion in a negative environment maybe
you can overpower it once or twice maybe
you can have the willpower to do the
right thing on one day but if you're
constantly fighting against those forces
it's going to be very hard to follow
through most people are familiar with
the story of the Good Samaritans
stopping along the side of the road to
help help a fallen person help someone
in need well Princeton their theology
school decided to run this experiment
they brought in a bunch of theology
students they said all right we're all
familiar with the story of the Good
Samaritan we're going to break you up
into groups and you're going to go teach
in different rooms across campus you're
going to teach this story and so they
started talking about you know how they
were going to deliver the presentation
and so on they had a couple different
cohorts the one cohort they said all
right just go ahead and you know go off
and uh and deliver the presentation so
they went off to their rooms the second
one though they did something
interesting they sent the group off but
on their way to the well they sent the
group off and they said by the way we're
running a little bit behind right you
don't have very long to get there it
takes about 10 minutes you only got five
so we kind of need to hurry you're
probably already going to be late so
they're in a rush they know they're
going to go give this presentation on
the way they planted an actor on the uh
on the campus and this actor is laying
on the grounds hurt moaning in pain and
so they scream twice and then they cry
out and every single group went right
past the person in need to go give a
presentation about helping a person in
need
right the one person even stepped over
the guy who was in pain in order to get
there now
the point of this and what I'd like to
start talking about now is the danger of
being goal focused and goal oriented
these people had a goal right to deliver
a presentation and they were so
one-sided so narrow-minded so focused on
that goal that they missed the bigger
picture and the perspective of what they
should have been doing in the first
place and I think that this can be a
danger of goals often and so instead I
would like to encourage us to focus on
systems systems rather than goals here's
some examples if your coach your goal is
to win a championship but your system is
what your team does at practice each day
if you're a writer you're going might be
to write a book maybe even write a
best-selling book but your system is how
you write each week the schedule that
you follow
if you're an entrepreneur your goal
could be to build a million dollar
business or a 10 million dollar business
but the system is the sales and
marketing process that you have the
systems are what actually make the
difference there would drive the results
and what I've seen having goals is great
having a vision having a dream is nice
it's important to know where you're
going and where you're headed it's
important to have some clarity of focus
to know that we're moving in this
direction but once you know that having
to go on paper makes very little
difference and committing to the system
and showing up every day drives a lot of
results often when we set about to
change something or to achieve something
the first step is almost always setting
a goal and this is coming from someone
like I was very goal-oriented for a long
time right like an asset yeah it's like
goals were the things I wanted to do in
sports the goals the grades I wanted in
class the goals for how much money I
want to make in my business
and sometimes I would achieve those but
then sometimes I wouldn't and so I had
this question like well clearly I'm
setting goals for both so like that
can't be the thing that determines it
and you see this a lot that the the
winners and losers in a particular
domain often have the same goals like
every Olympian wants to win a gold medal
sure uh every job candidate wants to get
the job so if the winners and the losers
have the same the same goal then the
goal cannot be the thing that
distinguishes the two and the thing that
distinguishes them is the process of the
system behind the goal and this is also
important because achieving a goal often
only changes your life for the moment
it's like you know say you're um
do just take like a simple example say
you have a messy room you know and you
set you get motivated and you set the
goal to clean your room well you can do
that in an hour and then you have a
clean room but if you don't change the
sloppy habits that led to a messy room
in the first place then you just end up
with a dirty room again yeah so it's
like treating a symptom without treating
the cause and
um habits are are a better solution in
that case because if you fix the inputs
the outputs fix themselves automatically
right you don't have to fight to have a
clean room if you have clean habits
um and I think that's true in a larger
sense as well right people want outcomes
they want to earn more money or lose
weight or be more productive or reduce
stress but the outcome is not the thing
that needs to change it's the system
that precedes it I remember seeing the
same thing I played baseball all the way
through college and you know like many
sports we had this kind of like hell
week in the beginning we're you know
training conditioning and everything
before the season starts and and um
I remember doing that in the morning we
it started at like 6 a.m and then you
know we got done and I was in class at
like you know nine or something and we
had a test and everybody's freaking out
and I was like this is so stupid to be
worried about this the like what I just
did to my body two hours ago or three
hours ago was so much harder than
whatever this quiz is going to be
um it just helps like recalibrate your
mind a little bit I think that's one
reason you know I mean I've spent the
last couple years writing about habits
and thinking about the stuff researching
the science like really working mentally
difficultly but what I've noticed is
that I need the physical Outlet too
because I don't think that you if you
only push yourself mentally I don't
think you get the full effect
um I think you need both and there's
something about pushing yourself
physically that strengthens yourself
mentally and also helps you just keep
perspective and recalibrate on all the
other stuff that you face in life you it
helps you put things in their proper
place you realize that you know most of
the things you're worried about are not
actually that big of a deal about 15
years ago early 2000s British cycling
hires guy named Dave brailsford and at
that point the last like 100 years
British cycling had been incredibly
mediocre they had won a single gold
medal back in 1908 they had never won a
Tour de France which is the premium race
and cycling the premier race and so they
uh they hired this guy named brailsford
to change that and in fact at the time
they were so mediocre that when they
went to buy a new set of bikes they're
gonna get like 200 from a top
manufacturer in Europe they actually
weren't even given quotes from the
manufacturer because they didn't want
other teams to see the British writers
using their gear uh for fair that would
it would hurt sales and uh so they
brought brailsford in and they said
what's your plan for changing this he
said well I believe in this philosophy
that I call the aggregation of marginal
gains the way that he described it as
the one percent Improvement in nearly
everything that you do so
they started with a bunch of things that
you would expect a cycling team to start
with so for example they put slightly
lighter tires on the bike they got a
more ergonomic seat for the Riders to
sit on they had their outdoor Riders
wear indoor racing suits because they
were lighter and more aerodynamic they
had each Rider where a biofeedback
sensor so they could see how they would
respond to training and then adjust it
appropriately for the person
but then they did a bunch of things you
wouldn't expect a cycling team to do so
they split tested different types of
massage gels to see which one led to the
best type of Muscle Recovery they toddy
tried her how to wash their hands to
reduce the risk of infections they
wouldn't get a cold after uh you know
and get sick they also figured out the
type of pillow that led to the best
night sleep for each Rider and then
brought that on the road with them to
hotels whenever they were competing and
brailsford said if we can actually do
this right if we can execute all these
little one percent improvements then I
think we can win a Tour de France within
five years
he ended up being wrong they wanted in
two years and then they repeat it again
the third year with a different Rider
and then after one year break they won
two more so they've won four out of the
last five now have gone to British
cyclists but it was at the Olympics in
London in 2012 when this kind of
strategy really came to fruition they
won 70 of the gold medals available
and so this idea that small improvements
tiny habits little choices are not just
a cherry on top of our performance not
just like a nice thing to have but
actually can be the key that unlocks
significant success that's an idea that
I want us to carry with us as we go
through the rest of this presentation
and one way to think about it is just
kind of basic math like if you just look
at the numbers if you were able to
improve by one percent each day for an
entire year and those gains compound you
would end up 37 times better at the end
of the year and if you were to get one
percent worse you would Whittle yourself
almost all the way down to zero and
what we what's interesting here is that
everybody wants a transformation right
everybody wants a radical Improvement we
want rapid success but we fail to
realize that small habits and little
choices are transforming us every day
already that these times when you make a
choice that's slightly better slightly
worse a little mistake or a small error
one percent better one percent worse
that these things compound over time and
habits are the compound interest of
self-improvement
and so if you can learn to master those
then you can make time work for you
rather than get against you right good
habits make time your ally bad habits
make time your enemy people have heard
things like this before start small
small steps whatever but even when you
know you should start small it's still
really easy to start too big so uh you
know say you want to get in shape and
you're like all right I want to run a
couple days a week but I know it should
start small so I'll only run for 15
minutes but even that is like way bigger
than what I'm talking about I mean it
should be so small that you in the book
I called the two minute rule but you
should downscale any Habit to fit within
two minutes so it's like all right I
want to go for a run three days a week
my habit is I put on my running shoes
and I step out the door anything else
that happens after that is just bonus
it's a success now sometimes people
resist that because they're like well
this sounds kind of like a mental trick
right like I know the real goal isn't
just to put my shoes on I know the real
goal is to go for a run so if you feel
that way my suggestion would be
only do the first two minutes for the
first few weeks because what you need to
do is Master the art of showing up like
I had a I had a reader who ended up
losing over 100 pounds and one of the
things that he did was he went to the
gym but he wasn't allowed to stay for
longer than five minutes so he would
show up be there do like half an
exercise five minutes ago he'd leave he
did this for like six weeks wow now it
sounds ridiculous it sounds silly
because it's just work out for a half
hour yeah yeah but what he was doing was
mastering the art of showing up and a
habit must be established before it can
be improved right if you don't establish
the Habit there's nothing to optimize if
you're not showing up at the gym every
day you don't even who cares about what
workout you're doing you're not even
there phone started running an hour a
day if you've never run in a long time
be the person who shows up and puts
their running shoes on every day before
you worry about how far you're running
and what kind of workout you're doing
and all that type of stuff there's this
thing called goodheart's law that says a
measure ceases to be a good measure when
it becomes the Target and so the point
is like imagine you're trying to lose
weight if you use the scale as a
measurement as a data point then yeah it
can be useful is like one signal into
your overall Health but if it becomes
the target if the whole mission of
getting in shape becomes about making
the scale go lower well then you start
doing a lot of unhealthy things just to
get the scale to move you know you may
say we may do some crazy juice cleanse
or some kind of radical diet or you end
up doing unhealthy things in the name of
moving the number and I think that
there's a lot of application of that in
creativity and business as well if the
number becomes the target then you kind
of lose sight of the bigger picture and
so I I feel like I try to remind myself
that measurements are just a
a piece of the larger puzzle and I can
use them to inform and make sure I'm
moving in the right direction but don't
spend too much time obsessing over any
individual metric why is something
rewarding why do you find it rewarding
and one of the reasons is because it
satisfies the craving that preceded the
action so
um
one way to put this is that perceived
value motivates you to act actual value
motivates you to repeat so it when you
buy something on Amazon you don't
actually buy the product like you don't
you don't buy the book because you don't
actually have it yet what you buy is the
image the product creates in your mind
you buy your expectation or the
perceived value of the sales page it's
only after you get the book and you read
it and you're like oh this is really
good that's when the actual value it
satisfies that craving you had before
and it reinforces oh hey this was
enjoyable I should do it again next time
so you kind of have both of those on on
each side of the the behavior social
norms Society leans heavily on us all so
uh if you there are just broad examples
of this so pressure religious pressure
media pressure all kinds of air pressure
yes
um
let's say so just some broad examples uh
you walk into an elevator and you turn
around to face the front you have a job
interview and you wear a suit and tie or
a dress or something nice there's no
reason it has to be that way right like
you could face the back of the elevator
you could wear a swimsuit to a job
interview but you don't do that because
it violates the shared Norms of the
group right it violates the shared
expectations of what that Society has
but that's not that's true not only in a
broad sense that we're part of these
tribes like big tribes you know what it
means to be a Christian or to be
American or to be Australian or whatever
but it's also true in the small tribes
that we belong to what it means to be a
neighbor on this street or a member of
your local CrossFit gym or to volunteer
for a local organization all of those
tribes all those groups that you belong
to have a set of shared expectations a
set of shared norms and the key if you
want to build habits that last if you
want to change the way that you
interpret cues
is to join a group where your the
desired behavior is the normal behavior
right like there are there are plenty of
people who they want to work out but
going to the gym feels like a lot to
them uh it feels hard feels like
sacrifice
but there are also people who go to the
gym every week and it's just normal it
doesn't feel like an obligation that's
the desired behavior is the normal
behavior their lifestyle right same
thing for uh musicians you know like if
you want to learn instrument hang out
with people who play all the time you
know like if you hang out with a bunch
of musicians it's like well yeah that's
what we do yeah we play four days a week
we play seven days a week because it
just happens that's that's what the
tribe does
the caveat to this and the thing that I
don't see people mention a lot is that
the reason social norms influence our
Behavior so much is because we want to
belong to the tribe we want to be
friends with those people and so we
don't want to lose the friendship or
lose belonging over violating the Norms
you're not going to hang out with a
bunch of vegans and have pork right and
just like be the only one eating that
you won't hang out with them for very
long because they're not going to be
friends with them anymore they'll kick
you out so you want to rise to the
standard of that group of that community
so the key I think is to join a group
where your desired behavior is a normal
behavior and you already have something
else in common with that group so Steve
cam is a good example of this so like
Steve runs nerd Fitness right and all
these people want to get in shape who
are coming into his community but they
also love Star Wars or Batman or
Spider-Man or you know all these other
things that nerds are into and if you
show up it can be intimidating to want
to get in shape or you know work out the
first time but if you can connect with
the group over your mutual love of Star
Wars then you're like oh well I'm
friends with these people and and now I
also want to pick up those other habits
with them because I want to belong with
the group because we're already friends
and so I think you can apply that
methodology to most new tribes that you
join don't just join a new tribe because
they have the desired Behavior also try
to find a way that you can overlap with
them find some shared context some other
stuff too yeah that you can Bond over
and then it's easier to adopt the habits
musicians that like to be healthy yeah
right if you want to do both right
finding that even subgroup it's like hey
we love you know we love playing music
and then also you're going to start
eating better because we all want to eat
healthy exactly yeah this is coming from
someone who's been very goal oriented
for a long time so I would set goals for
the grades I wanted to get in school or
the weights I wanted to lift in the gym
or the amount of Revenue I want in my
business or how many email subscribers I
wanted like all of that and at some
point I realized you know I'm setting
all these goals like am I actually
achieving some of them and sometimes I
would but there were plenty of times
where I failed and so I had this
realization that well if that's the case
then setting a goal cannot be the thing
that means whether or not I achieve
success and if you think about this the
winners and losers in any domain a lot
of the time they have the same goals you
know like every person who applies for a
job has the goal of getting the job
every Olympian has the goal of winning
the gold medal and so if winners and
losers have the same goals then the goal
can't be the thing that makes the
difference
and I don't mean that goals are useless
I think goals are actually quite useful
for setting a sense of direction or
knowing um you know which basically what
area the the boat should be pointed in
what direction the boat should point in
where you're trying to row but once
you've decided that it's probably more
useful to put the goal on the shelf and
focus exclusively on the system or the
process and in my language habits make
up the system and they're like this
collection of ha of behaviors and
patterns that you perform each day and
when you put them all together you end
up with this system that delivers a
result and whatever your results are in
Life or in business or wherever your
current system is perfectly designed to
deliver them it has to be by definition
that's why you're getting those results
so if you want different results what
you need is not really a different goal
we need as a different system this is
one of the most common uh I guess
criticisms or complaints that people ask
me about with habits is like well you
know I don't want to be robotic right
like what about like spontaneity what
about the you know freedom and doing
what I want you know I don't want to
like pigeonhole myself in this lifestyle
but uh it's this false dichotomy because
habits don't restrict Freedom they
create it you know it's often the people
who have the worst habits that have the
least amount of Freedom it's the people
who have terrible financial habits that
are always wondering like where the next
dollar will come from or it's the people
who have poor learning habits that are
always one like feeling like they're
behind the curve
um or people who have poor Fitness
habits that are always struggling to
find energy but on the other hand if you
have your habits dialed in if you like
you know have your your Fitness habits
figured out if you've got your finances
handled then you actually have way more
freedom than you did before now you
actually have the space to you have the
energy to do what you want you have the
strength to do what you want you have
the financial ability to spend time in
areas that you want
um
and all of that comes from getting your
habits handled so it's it's uh it is a
little counterintuitive this idea that
like discipline equals Freedom or habits
do not restrict Freedom they create it
but it's it's true that if you can
handle that stuff if the fundamentals of
Life are dialed in then you've got space
for spontaneity and creativity and
freedom and all the other stuff in a
sense you could say that every behavior
is driven by the desire for a change in
state and so when you
um smoke a cigarette or eat a bag of
Doritos or pick up your phone what you
really want is not the nicotine or the
calories from the Doritos or the
um the likes on social media what you
want is to feel less anxious or to feel
approved or to
um not be bored anymore so it's really
the desire to change that state that
you're in that motivates you to act and
the behavior and in many cases a lot of
our modern technology is an example of
this you didn't we didn't evolve you
didn't come out of the womb with like a
desire to check Instagram right like
there's nothing evolutionarily wired
there it's just a modern manifestation
of an ancient desire to gain respect and
approval or to not be abandoned by the
tribe or to feel approved and you know
in some capacity and uh so we kind of
have those like deeper Primal drives and
then the secondary layer on top of it is
just the modern manifestation of that
behavior and how we're resolving it in
the moment the first stage of every
habit is a cue the second stage is a
craving or some kind of prediction that
your brain makes I'll give you an
example of these in a second the third
stage is the response and then the
fourth stage is the reward
so you walk into a um the question I had
that that no model I could find could
solve in any good way or explain in any
good way was why can the same person
respond to the same cue in a different
way so let's say you get into the habit
of going to the gym at five o'clock
every day but then sometimes work gets
busy and you don't go to the gym at five
o'clock current models don't explain
that very well because it's like well
the Q is five you should be going to the
gym right now it says you the routine
Falls automatically up to the queue
or why uh why does someone
walk into the kitchen and see a plate of
cookies and then they automatically want
to eat it but you could just as imagine
just as easily imagine that you just got
done eating dinner in the other room and
you're stuffed and you're full and you
walk in you see a plate of cookies
you're like I'm stuffed I don't want to
eat anything so what's going on there
and I think these four stages explain it
which is you see the cue or you
experience a cue and then you're craving
your prediction differs based on your
current state so the way that you
interpret the cues in your life is
contingent upon the current state that
you're in the way you're feeling right
and also other things like your beliefs
or your identity the social group that
you're part of right so like if you're
in a different group then maybe you
interpret things in a different way you
know you can imagine one group they
practice a particular religion they walk
into a butcher shop and see pork and
they don't they're like oh we can't eat
that right another person walks in and
they're like oh yeah I'll pork sandwich
because it's obvious and easy and right
there so what you choose is contingent
upon how you interpret the cues in your
life it's this idea between the system
and the goal and uh you know like say
you're you're playing a sport in every
sport the goal is to have the best score
on the scoreboard at the end of the game
but it would be ridiculous to spend all
game looking at the scoreboard because
they wouldn't help you in any way so in
fact if you just ignored the score the
entire time and just focus on a better
process or playing it a better way or a
better scheme or strategy then you
probably would end up with the best
score
um I think Bill Walsh she was the Super
Bowl winning head coach for the San
Francisco 49ers he had this quote it was
like the score takes care of itself and
that I think that probably applies to a
lot of tracking and measurement there
are a couple ways to think about it but
I would say just quick definition a
habit is a behavior that has been
repeated enough times to be performed
more or less automatically so you can do
it pretty much on autopilot but another
way to think about it and I think this
is a useful way to define a habit is
that as you go through life you face
different problems and some of those
problems are big and some of them are
small like you need to tie your shoes
and whenever you face a problem your
brain starts looking for solutions to
that and as you come across solutions to
the recurring problems in life you start
to automate those and so every morning
you wake up and you put your shoes on
and you got this little problem that you
need to solve and pretty soon after you
tie your shoes 100 times or 500 times or
thousand times you can do it pretty much
without thinking and so that's another
way of thinking about habits is that
they're kind of these like automatic
Solutions we fall into for whatever the
recurring problems are we face right
behavior that becomes habituated yeah
and you know like they're the
interesting thing about this is you
don't necessarily have to have the same
Habit to solve a recurring problem like
if you come home from work each day and
you feel stressed and exhausted one
person might uh play video games for an
hour and that's a way to resolve that
problem so they get in the habit of
doing it and they just walk over the
controller they don't think about it
another person might go for a run for 20
minutes or meditate for 10 minutes the
third person might smoke a cigarette and
all all of those are just solutions to
that problem that you're facing and that
I think is another powerful lesson is
that your original habit is not
necessarily the optimal one and once you
realize that then it kind of becomes
your responsibility to become a little
more aware of what those habits are and
then think about it can you shape them
or design them right so in a sense
habits are the path through which you
can reshape your self-image because if
you this is one reason why I believe in
small habits you know if you um save a
really crazy day at work and you don't
have time to do a full workout well
doing five push-ups it's easy to like
dismiss that and be like well that's not
going to do anything it doesn't get me
in shape but if you do five push-ups
then you reinforce you cast a vote for
the identity of I'm the type of person
who doesn't miss workouts even if it
wasn't ideal even if I didn't have much
time even if the best I could do after
this 12 hour flight was to do five
push-ups and then crash in the hotel bed
um I still didn't miss a workout and the
cumulative effect of that of reinforcing
your your desired identity I think it's
really big in the long run and if it's
if it's meaningful then it actually is
Big even if the action is small and so
that's one reason I believe in small
habits is that they are the pathway
through which you can like reshape your
self-image and um that I think is the
real reason habits matter it's true they
can like habits can help you get in
shape or be more productive or reduce
stress or make more money and all those
external results are great but the real
thing that they do is they reinforce and
embody the identity of the the type of
person that you want to be
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Alex for Mosey
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there I think that when
I started out in business I heard all
these things in the personal development
space like oh you should have you should
read these affirmations every morning I
never did that and it was because it
felt stupid to me now that being said
there might be some people who've had
life-changing results from doing that